[Musique]
emmanuel macron comme son gouvernement
sont des comédiens plus tôt pour être
pas être désagréable avec les comédiens
des mauvais comédien et donc ils font de
la comédie alors gérald darmanin va
prononcer des mots il va faire des
déplacements il assagi t il à s'énerver
il va essayer de me mais nicolas sarkozy
sauf qu'il n'a ni le talent ni
l'autorité politique mais ça fait pas
une politique
ça fait pas une action publique la
vérité c'est que depuis trois ans les
chiffres de la délinquance des actes de
violence à l'égard des forces de l'ordre
comme à l'égard de nos concitoyens ont
explosé c'est plus de 21 % en trois ans
et il faudra un peu plus que la comédie
pour être le président de la république
qu'ils se saisissent d'ailleurs des
questions de sécurité c'est une bonne
chose mais il a trois ans de retard les
indicateurs sont très mauvais on voit
bien que en 2019 + 8 % 2 de coups et
blessures il y à 110 fait par jour
d'attac de gendarmes de policiers de
pompiers
45% des peines de prison ferme ne sont
pas exécutés dans les six mois
donc il ya véritablement le feu dans la
maison là à un moment donné il faut
aussi se rendre compte que la défiance
qui a et qui existe aujourd'hui entre
d'un côté la police la gendarmerie
l'autre côté le pouvoir politique en
place le président de la république et
le gouvernement
c'est aussi en grande partie la faute du
gouvernement qui lorsqu'il a fallu
défendre la police a préféré prendre le
pas et défendre les manifestants
violents contre la police en donnant des
ordres complètement complètement fou
vous rendez compte ça fait trois ans
qu'ils explosent la question
d'insécurité en france un sondage de la
semaine après semaine dernière est sorti
70% des français expriment être en
situation d'insécurité ou de quoi se
sentir en insécurité l'explosion de
l'insécurité dans les transports en
commun une explosion d'insécurité dans
les quartiers il zone de non droit n'ont
jamais été traitées pendant ces trois
années qui viennent de s'écouler que ce
gouvernement j'entends un collègue qui
dit le temps passe vite j'ai
l'impression que c'est plutôt les
priorités qui passent vite avec ce
gouvernement qui n'a pas agi pour donner
les moyens aux forces de l'ordre qui a
mis en place une politique pénale qui
continuait celle de christiane taubira
donc il ya un écart très important entre
les paroles que nous entendons et les
actes
qui sont mis en oeuvre nous les
républicains nous proposons c'est
d'aider les eaux grâce au travail de
christian jacob et des actes d
appréciation des uns des autres on
propose évolué de 0,8 pour cent du pib
pour la sécurité à 1 % sur cinq ans ce
qui est un effort considérable désormais
faut passer du gouvernement des bandes
annonces
vous avez misé l'intérieur qui se
déplacent matin midi et soir un
gouvernement des résultats et c'est sur
les résultats les acomptes jugera
pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui à une
crise d'autorité
il ya une crise de confiance c'est
l'insécurité c'est le problème numéro un
des français et on voit bien que la
france allait malade de son insécurité
et que l'on constate tous les jours
le nombre d'agressions ces 700
agressions par jour dont 100 pour les
dépositaires de la force publique
donc c'est là-dessus qu'il faut agir
vite et fort
[Musique]